over the weekend afghan government
troops in the north of the country
abandoned their posts
and fled to neighboring tajikistan the
reason
a taliban advanced they felt they were
ill-equipped to oppose
it's a pattern playing out across the
country with the taliban now controlling
some one-third of the country's 421
districts
these gains come as international troops
continue to pull out from the country
a scenario that's left many afghans
worried about their future
these afghan people are determined to
leave the country
that's why thousands of them have
gathered at this passport office in
capital kabul
trying to find a way out
their future has become too uncertain as
the effect of the us troops withdrawal
starts to unfold
most of the districts have fallen
there's not a single district without
fighting
the taliban have even reached the chief
of police's office and provincial
capitals
i've come here to get my passport and
get out of afghanistan
it's not safe here many
embassies have registered a dramatic
increase in the number of visa and
passport applications
as the taliban advances people fear the
hard-won
progress over the past two decades will
start to roll back
women and girls for example went from
near total exclusion from public life
to being able to work and study in mixed
schools today
now these gains are hanging in the
balance
very recently we have reports that as
districts that have been taken over by
the taliban
they have already imposed restrictions
on women on media for instance women
are in in tahar reportedly not allowed
to leave the house without a male
chaperone clinics have been closed
there's also
reports of media blackout this is
happening
despite the taliban's promises that the
public has
nothing to fear
and the situation could intensify
the group has already made significant
territorial gains
in the past months
afghan forces are struggling to hold
them off
now our people thinking if govern our
government cannot to control
this situation maybe the civil war will
be stored so that's the main problem why
people
trying to go abroad
those who couldn't afford a visa are
seeking to leave illegally
many of them are young people
they're about to cross the border to
iran before embarking on further
journeys
hoping to secure a better future
one section of afghan citizens that's
particularly concerned about its future
are its women
and for more on that i'm joined by aisha
khoram a law student at kabul university
and a former afghan youth representative
to the u.n aisha nearly 50 of
afghanistan's population is
women how worried are they about life
under possible taliban influence
well if we look at the rapid
and unconditional withdrawal of the used
troops and
since the announcement of united states
and nato
troops which are all from afghanistan we
can see that
the slightest hope for peace also
vanished
and right now there is a windless
mentality on the ground and taliban are
getting more territory
and it's leaving a lot of people
uh not only women but all afghanistan is
worried about what is to come
um and now the future of the peace
process the future of afghanistan and
the younger generation is
it's all in in ambiguity it's in
question
now taliban as you correctly point out
have rapidly advanced across the country
from what you
are hearing can you describe for us what
the situation is particularly for women
in the areas that they control
well women right now women living in
some of the districts uh
their situation was relatively uh
better since 2001 however there is a
huge gap of opportunities and facilities
when it comes to urban and rural areas
of afghanistan
but the relative success and the
relative
security the relative progress that
women had even in the forest
district of afghanistan it was something
to be preserved
and protected and right now um as
taliban are gaining more territory as um
the government is staying silent about
it and as the united states is
withdrawing irresponsibly it all makes
um women more frightened
of what is to come and right now we are
left with no guarantee
of any future that we could look forward
to now we are also getting reports that
the
taliban are being welcomed in some of
the areas
that they are capturing what explains
this support
for the taliban
well in some of the districts
that are um right now and the taliban's
control
over the years uh when there were
airstrikes and where they were
some of the war crimes committed by
revolving government and the
international community
it really created this um this uh
sense of uh peop among people that they
could
uh rely on on a community
uh on on the people who are from those
communities who
are rising against the government but
does not particularly mean they are
supporting talwan's ideology
you see in the past 20 years a
generation was raised and born in this
conflict
now they even forgot what this war even
started at the beginning
at the first place and right now they
are fighting
even not knowing for what reason so
some of the people are even joining one
or another side
just for the sake of survival talk to me
a bit about
the conservative nature of afghan
society i mean how much of a priority
is girls education or women's
participation in politics for example
among the general population
well in 20 years ago when united states
and nato
started engagement military engagement
in afghanistan i was one year old
born as a refugee in peshawar and i
returned to afghanistan after 2001 with
my family i
was a child i grew up here i went to
school i went
to university i'm still at university
and you see that back then when
everything started
from from the very beginning of we were
building from the scratch we were
building from the ashes there was a lot
of hope a lot of optimism
and women were accomplished in the
society but today
everything is unquestioned including the
future of women's education and the most
concerning of all is
the increased level of violence but
besides that even during the peace
process
the language about the human rights and
the rights of women in the post peace
afghanistan was ambiguous and that was
a very concerning point for a lot of
women
we leave it there for the time being but
thank you so much for joining us today
and afghanistan's neighbor pakistan has
long been seen as having influence over
the taliban
for that reason pakistan's involvement
in the peace process
is seen as crucial to its outcome
relations between pakistan and the
taliban go
way back the group itself was formed in
the early 90s
primarily by pashtun students in
pakistani madrasas
or islamic religious schools pakistan
was one of only
three countries that recognized the
taliban when it ruled afghanistan
between 1996 and 2001 and in the last
few years
pakistan has played a key role in
bringing the taliban
to the talks table for more let's head
to correspondent
jalani in karachi in pakistan she said
aside from pakistan's influence over the
taliban
what is driving pakistani engagement
with the afghan peace process
viresh the conventional wisdom around
the world is that
because of pakistan's deep involvement
in afghanistan over the last
four decade decades and its closeness to
the taliban
taliban are often seen as pakistan's
proxies
but what we are hearing now from
pakistani army leadership
is that they are losing influence with
taliban
last week the pakistani army chief and
the head of its
isi the intelligence agency was briefing
a panel of parliamentarians and they
were told
that they don't have as much influence
with taliban
as people seem to think and there's
growing anxiety within pakistan
that if things go haywire next door
pakistan will face
a really difficult time so we've also
heard from other think tanks like the
international crisis group
in washington last week they are also
saying that pakistan's influence
may not be as much with taliban as we
generally seem to think so it's an open
question
how much pakistan can really tell
taliban
in terms of coming to peace negotiations
or renouncing violence
what are the fears in pakistan that if
afghanistan does not go down the
peace route as it were what will happen
what will be the effect on pakistan
so you know analysts journalists think
tanks have been saying for uh for a
while now
that we are headed uh for a very
difficult period
in this region but now we are hearing it
from pakistan's
army leadership from political
leadership
the biggest fear is taliban gaining more
and more territory
eventually taking over kabul
and then pakistan also facing a problem
in terms of the pakistani taliban
becoming more active
there are already reports there's
evidence that in pakistan's tribal areas
next to afghanistan
taliban and other militants are picking
up peace and activity
so the big fear is there will be more
militancy in pakistan
and if afghanistan does descend into
chaos and anarchy
and civil war there will be more
refugees the country already has three
million refugees
and there will be people coming across
the border so
those are the major fears at the moment
what is the thinking in pakistan
does pakistan believe the taliban should
be a part of any interim government
in afghanistan for instance
officially pakistan says it has no
favorites it believes that whatever
happens in afghanistan should be abhan
owned
afghan led but we know from pakistan's
deep involvement
with the taliban the way it delivered
taliban for example for negotiation with
the u.s
that it would prefer if taliban were in
power
i mean we have to recognize that taliban
are now an internationally
recognized entity the u.s had an
agreement with them
pakistan iran india is engaging with
them
and russia and china have hosted them
jalani we'll leave it there for the time
being but thank you so much for this
update from karachi pakistan